[Music]
[Applause]
and
wright thompson joins us now i thought
about you as i often do right
with urban meyer going through
everything that he's going through i
went back and re-read your profile of
irving meyer
is he wired to be an nfl head coach in
your opinion
i mean it's funny because i went back i
never go read one
and uh i read it not that long ago
and
so to cop out on your original question
i don't know if he is i think he
is wired to try to be successful at
anything
and i think that like many many
successful people
the things that make him great are so
closely tied to
the things that ultimately cause him to
self-destruct
that it's sort of hard to say uh i
one of the things i always liked about
urban meyer
is that he and you know how rare this is
he seems to be self-aware enough in
moments to understand
all of his own worst impulses and his
inability to control them
and like i found that really interesting
that like
he could still sort of see the guy in
the mirror and that is
uh pretty rare but also
he doesn't step on the field 99 of the
time with the best talent
the best team now he's going to step on
the field and then i wonder
what that losing does to him when you
lose more games in a season than you do
in five years
you know how does that penetrate urban
meyer
and it's just a different job i mean it
is just fundamentally a different job
and so you know i was with i was there
when he talked to his first ever
recruiting class
like their first week at ohio state and
he talked about
the sound the crowd made when they came
out of the tunnel
and he talked about the sound five rings
made when they would slam their hand
down on the podium when they got their
diploma
and like describe to them coming back
here with their kids and grandkids
and it's just like that that's a shtick
that's unfair that's cynical and unfair
but it is
that thing has an audience and that
audience is not an nfl locker room
uh and then i just wondered health wise
like you're around him
is is he aware of his health
and what it did to him what the job does
to him
i think well this is what we were just
talking about i mean i think
intellectually he knows his wife shelly
who's great
uh you know i don't think she would let
him go back if she didn't believe that
he was okay
but i mean it's sort of i mean it's a
little bit of a dry drunk
you know i mean it the propensity to
lose yourself in this rabbit hole
is always there and it is interesting
that he knows this is a fire that burns
him but he keeps going back to it
and i mean that to me is his interesting
thing to watch is what the team does on
the field
when you heard about tim tebow and the
possibility
your first reaction was i mean of course
you know there are many ways to describe
urban uh
that are charitable and uncharitable and
uh most of them are true
i've always thought he's just a guy
who's desperate for a belief system
and i think he finds tim tebow's
certainty to be reassuring
and because and i mean look this is now
we're now we've ventured into
psychobabble but like
urban is is a guy searching for a thing
to believe in
and so it makes sense that people who
really believe something
whether that is an offensive philosophy
or you know
the four books of the gospel he is
attracted to that
always paulie give wright the poll
question today
all right if this is based off bob
baffert and the preakness
would you rather be considered a cheater
or incompetent
reckless wow
i think i would rather oh wow that's
hard i mean
i guess i would rather be seen as
incompetent and reckless
is bob baffert a cheater or
reckless
i was just talking about this with
people and i honestly don't know the
answer
i mean i find it hard to believe that
someone would be that careless that
close to a race like that
but it's also you know i mean
bob baffert is nick saban and these
horses are the five-star recruits
and he sees them in their living room
and he sees them on senior day
and you know that's not a stretch to say
that their players at alabama
who after their recruiting visit will
never be alone in a room with nick saban
again
and so like if you're an owner and
you're hiring bob baffert you're buying
the bob baffert experience
and so the thing that will be tricky for
bob is to
accurately explain what's going on at
the barn
and not destroy the myth i mean he's a
ceo
i mean that's what these guys do at this
level when you have that many horses
but i think if you have a million dollar
horse in your head you you know you've
seen the movies you imagine bob baffert
stroke him and whispering to him at five
o'clock in the morning and
you know like it just it doesn't work
like that and so
you know this is the classic dangerous
scandal because
uh just below the news is the really
potentially damaging thing
for an entire way of doing business but
i don't know if you saw his
interview with me or heard about it but
i said
bob have you taken inventory with your
staff like if
before you do scorched earth don't you
ask like don't you start with your
veterinarian and just say
i just want to make sure because i'm
going to get in front of the cameras and
i'm
going at people and like he had canceled
culture
he had sabotage and you're going if i
just
let me start with a veterinarian
yeah just like can somebody tell me
every single thing
that has touched this horse and if any
of those things have this thing in it
you would think that would be the first
question well you see the cream
it's right there on it you see this this
anti-inflammatory or fungal thing right
there
on the label sometimes you just got to
look in mark maguire's locker
you know but like it's just right there
i mean it's very i don't know
i don't know the answer to that but
that's the that's the million-dollar
question but do you think horse racing
fans care
no and i mean i think this is the now
we're at the real question
which is is horse racing
designed for a transparent world in
which scrutiny
exists and the answer frankly might be
no
and it was very interesting to me to see
how hard churchill downs came
out against baffert because the only two
real centers of power in
horse racing as it exists in popular
culture are the kentucky derby and bob
baffert
so the fact that they turned on each
other almost immediately
uh within hours was really interesting
because
maybe they know something we don't know
but there
it seems your fans don't care
and would rather just not think about it
so it seems
a very strategically interesting
move by them and you know it makes me
wonder
you know i hate maybe they're just like
fed up and like
or maybe they know something we don't
know but it was just it was very
interesting to see
the only two things only two household
names and horse racing
turn on each other within several hours
what are you working on now
man i am uh going to manchester england
in two weeks for my
uh it's the first international trip
post covid and i'm writing a story about
man united supporters uh specifically in
a couple of really
old neighborhoods can i go with you you
can absolutely come with me
i gotta quit this job and and like get
divorced
i'll do it well i mean for you
you're gonna lose your house so you
might have to come with me okay
yeah man because you love yourself some
soccer but
is it the soccer or is it the fans i
like the fan
well i mean both but in this instance i
like
i like man united uh man city liverpool
i like those uh teams in those towns
that were the cradle of the industrial
revolution
you know manchester united started as
the
company softball team essentially for
the lancashire and yorkshire railroad
and so you know the this thing has
roots in
in the industrial revolution so i find
it interesting that
the the forces that changed all these
people's lives and created these teams
were the forces of globalism that
manchester and liverpool and london sit
out into the world
and now they've arrived back on their
shores in the form of globalist owners
of their teams and they don't like it
which i don't blame them but it is
interesting that like you sent this
boomerang out into the world and now it
has finally come back to you
by the way uh wright thompson is a 2021
american society of magazine editors
awards finalists feature writing
category for michael jordan history of
flight
uh i know you didn't ask me to mention
that but fritzy got me that information
there
uh what do you want people to know about
that article that
you did on michael jordan that profile
that
that michael that the key to understand
the key to really seeing michael jordan
i think is understanding how country he
grew up
and how country his family is and you
know he grew up
on grandparents and great-grandparents
farms
in the country outside of wilmington
people think wilmington but they lived
on the very edge of wilmington
and until his father moved there they
had always lived
in this tiny little square of north
carolina there's burgaw
up there there are a bunch of places
that listeners probably know about and
so he's very very country
and you know his defining his defining
memory of his father growing up is his
dad
out working on a car in the driveway
with the car on blocks and running
around in the woods with his brothers
and so so seeing that
explains a lot of things about how he
became like he is
i mean michael knew michael knew his
great-grandfather who was the son of a
slave
i mean it the history shrinks in on
itself i mean i love
to go places where the the membrane
between past and present is as thin as
possible
and there are a lot of places like that
all over eastern north carolina where
michael jordan grew up
do you ever profile happy people
yes dale murphy dude oh you're right
but is that boring because murph is one
of the great people not great athletes
great people i've ever met
it was i mean i don't want to wax on
murph too much but it was life-changing
for me
in that it allowed god i can't believe
i'm saying this this is like a therapy
session
uh it allowed me to see the dangers of
sort of my own ambition
because i was confronted with a guy who
had come out the other side
and had made the correct choices and was
very very happy
and was happy with his family both in
how he saw them and how they saw him
and i just walked away thinking well
this guy this is the closest i've ever
seen to the secret of life on display
i mean one of the you know you talked
about happy land i mean one of the
things that was really driving that book
is
i mean i started on that pretty soon
after i was with murph
and it was i mean it was if anything
that book is a road
map for me to try to figure out how to
be
more like dale murphy
that's high praise that's how i pray for
murphy he's something
you know he's oh my gosh he's just good
he's and it's real
and like you shouldn't meet your
childhood heroes
so i was very nervous about that because
i was like if dale murphy's a jerk i'm
honestly
i don't believe in anything anymore i
remember meeting pete maravich
and i just wanted him to be a good guy
and and i don't know if he was
but but it stayed with me you know
you're right uh
you be careful what you asked for uh hey
hope family's good
and uh play nice when you go over there
to england all right
well i will i know i'm very excited for
my full english breakfast
i have to quarantine for five days in a
hotel which
as a parent of two toddlers sounds great
have some blood pudding over there
uh-huh yeah i'll have whatever as long
as i can sleep in
thank you right great to talk to you
buddy that's uh wright thompson espn
senior writer and get your copy of
the book happy land online wherever
books are sold and really it's a
wonderful father's day gift